[Captions by Y Translator]
Guys, we are back once again
with my friend Joseph,
and today, we're going to use some of
the things we've made before...
Including the bag bellows
from the previous video,
and this furnace
that was teased also
in the previous video.
And today,
we are going to try
and extract iron, from iron ore.
[Music]
>> So, blacksmithing is primitive.
You're like raw, dealing
with the elements,
beating on a piece of iron,
but where did the blacksmith
get the iron?
And that's what
we're doing today.
We are going to make iron.
> So what materials are we
going to start with?
I know we've got our bellows,
and we've got our bloom furnace,
which is basically
a cylinder of clay.
>> Yes, a cylinder of clay
with a hole in the bottom,
so that we can pump air into it.
>> All right.
What else do we need?
>> We need to make
basically a lasagna
out of ore and charcoal.
And what's going to happen is,
as the fire burns,
it's going to sink
down into the fire.
And what we're going
to keep doing is adding
a little bit more charcoal,
and then a little bit more ore,
and it's going to make layers,
like lasagna on its way down.
And on its way down,
It's going to get hot,
but the heat is not
what converts this into metal.
You can get this crazy hot,
and what you would have
is molten red rocks.
In order to make iron,
you need a chemical
reaction to happen.
And for that,
our secret ingredient
is charcoal.
Charcoal is basically
pure carbon,
and when it burns,
it produces carbon monoxide.
This is why you should
never ever burn it inside.
The temperature is going to melt
off all of the glassy
stuff, all the silica,
and then the carbon monoxide
is literally going to rip
off oxygen atoms
from the iron ore,
leaving us with iron.
>> So we've got this full.
There's a little bit
of wood down at the bottom.
The top layer is pretty much
all charcoal this point,
and then we have
our first batch of iron oxide.
It's not even slightly warm yet,
because not much oxygen
is getting into this.
So the fire is staying very low,
until we use the bellows
to flood it with oxygen,
and just get it blazing hot.
>> And you can think of it
in different temperature zones.
Up here, it's
like just drying off,
if there's any moisture
in the ore or the charcoal.
And as it gets
a little bit lower,
it'll heat up,
and then right around here,
it'll get hot enough
that it will start converting.
And then, it will get close
to the oxygen again,
but what we're pumping
in is oxygen,
and that's exactly the thing
we're trying to get rid of.
So what will happen is
the iron bits are going
to turn into iron,
and then as the come past here,
there's a danger
that will turn back into rust.
Fortunately,
we have a secret ingredient,
also included an ore,
and that is the glassy
stuff, the sand.
And so that's going to melt
and coat all of those little
particles of ore,
protecting them from the oxygen
until they settle down here,
in the bottom zone of the fire.
>> Let's pump some air.
Let's do it.
[Music]
So we're doing right here is
we are pre-roasting the ore.
This is particularly useful
for hydrated ores,
in other words,
ores that have water molecules
bound it onto them,
similar to the way that concrete
has water bound on to it,
and so, what we're doing
is we're roasting it,
and the other thing
that it does is it makes
it way easier to grind
to down into the pea
gravel and powder size
that we need to put
it in the furnace.
Joseph and I tried grinding
this up, like normal,
and it was miserable.
So roasting it as a good thing.
When you find reddish rocks,
like in say,
the Grand Canyon area,
it doesn't take very
much iron to stay in rock red.
So just because it's red,
doesn't mean there's
a lot of iron there.
The first smelt I did
with iron failed miserably
because I had red rocks,
and I assumed
that they were iron.
Turns out,
they only had like
three percent iron,
and tested that
after I failed with it.
[Music]
>> All right, we want
to do an update.
This has been running
for several hours,
and, although we did use
the bag bellows for many hours,
we also did decide it's okay
if we cheat a little bit.
>> Especially since we
ran into a problem
where we were not going
through enough ore fast enough
to finish within like a day.
In order to speed things up,
we got an electric air pump,
and that goes a lot faster.
The bag bellows was working.
We were getting
everything processing.
It was just processing slowly.
>> And it was so cool.
Well, except for the fact
that it was hot in the sun,
and next to a 2000
degree furnace.
But other than that,
it was cool.
>> We opened up the back
of it to try and let
some slag burn out.
Slag is everything
that's in the iron ore
that isn't the iron itself,
and we found
that we believe we have
a good sized lump of iron.
>> Now, this could be
just a bunch of slag,
or it could be a bunch
of iron and slag,
so we can cool that off.
>> Cool that off first.
Yeah, let's put
that in a bucket of water.
[Music]
What do you think it was,
mostly iron or mostly slag?
>> Mostly slag.
Okay, big old blob of slag.
So the way to tell is
you whack it with a hammer.
If it shatters, it's slag.
If it dents, it's iron.
And as you can see,
it's probably a little
over 200 degrees.
The cool thing about this is
the partially reduced bits,
I can just throw
back on the fire,
and we can recycle this.
[Music]
>> At this point,
we have enough heat
in our bloom furnace
that we have slag pouring out.
This stuff looks like lava,
and since a lot
of its melted rock,
it kind of is lava.
It's just lava from rocks
that used to have
a lot of iron in it.
[Music]
Getting slag this runny
is a good sign
because it usually means
there is a higher concentration
of iron in the ore,
and so the fact
that we are seeing this
as a very good sign.
Slag is [inaudible]
>> Yes, holy crap!
That is iron.
[Music]
So, the furnace has been burning
for a very, very long time.
You may notice from the lighting
that it's late afternoon.
And what we've done is
we've managed to get
through all the ore
in those layers,
and I can feel with this thing
that there's a big lump
of something right there.
Is it iron?
Please be iron.
[Music]
>> Now you can see how thick
the walls are on this thing.
Oh boy.
That's a big old
blob of something.
>> Is it iron?
>> I can't tell yet.
>> I'm going to clear out
some of that charcoal.
And again, right here.
[Music]
>> More?
>> More.
Yes.
Keep going.
Nice.
Okay.
Is it loose?
>> Not really.
Oh, come on.
Where are you?
[Music]
>> Oh, you were really close
to cracking that.
[Music]
That is an iron bloom.
>> Let me see that hammer log.
[Music]
>> Should I get my hands dirty?
>> Yes, please do.
[Music]
Okay, let's try
to get a piece out,
put it on this wooden anvil,
and then compress it.
[Music]
Whack it!
Now's the time to compress.
Nate, go for broke.
You want to be gentle at first,
but see if you can get
it compressing on itself at all.
[Music]
>> It looks like a meteor.
>> It does.
You can see it deforming at all?
>> I think so.
>> Nice.
[Music]
No!
Okay, so this purplish red rust
that we see up here,
that's a really good sign,
as is that bluish
stuff right there.
Like this...
>> Hold that [inaudible].
>> That lump maybe.
This is iron.
I'm going to join a heavy metal band
because of how awesome this feels.
That is so cool.
>> So there's...
Is there still slag in this,
or do you think this is
pure iron at this point?
>> This is got tons of slag,
and probably even
some charcoal in it.
>> All right Joseph,
so we started out
with a bunch of red dirt.
>> Yes.
And a bunch of charcoal.
Well actually,
we start out with red rocks,
and we had to grind them down
painstakingly into red dirt.
Yes.
>> So we just burned it
for like six or seven hours.
Yes.
>> Yes, we just burn it for six to seven hours.
>> And now we got this.
Yep.
Very cool.
So this right here
should be able to be turned
into a block of iron,
similar to what Joseph
has made before.
To get this to turn
into something like that,
it will involve some heat,
some hammering,
maybe gathering up pieces
as it smashes out all
the remaining slag and charcoal
that's stuck in this.
But this should have quite a bit
of good refinable iron in it.
And next, Joseph
is going to take this,
and turn it into a brick,
kind of like this,
and at that point,
you can start blacksmithing it.
>> So hardcore!
This is so cool!
Yeah!
>> He's a little bit excited.
Yeah, this is pretty cool.
I haven't done this five times
before to varying levels
of success to have
his seen level of excitement,
but I am quite happy
that this turned out.
I'm quite happy
for the knowledge he already had
and shared with us
to make sure this did turn out,
and I'm really interested to see
what gets made out of it.
>> Thanks. I'll have to show you.
It would be great.
>> Guys, that's it for today,
but there's always more for you to see.
That box up at the top
will take you to our last video,
and you should check
that one out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should do watching next,
and if you hit this bomb
in the middle,
you will be subscribe
to the channel,
and that way, you'll never miss
out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.